yeah LGBTQ teenagers are lied to about
what it is to be a gay or lesbian or bi
or trans adult they're misinformed
they're not just bullied at school by
their peers they're bullied at home by
their parents all too often and all too
often then dragged off to churches on
Sunday for more bullying from the pulpit
and it's important then for gay and
lesbian adults to reach out to these
kids and share our stories so that they
can picture futures for themselves that
are happy that are worth sticking around
for when a thirteen-year-old kills
himself because he's gay what he's
saying is I can't picture a future for
myself with enough joy in it to
compensate for the pain I'm in now and
gay and lesbian and buying trans adults
we need to share our stories with these
kids they can picture those futures not
one future that's why there's thousands
of videos up on the website all from all
different kinds of game lesbian and bi
and trans people but picture a future
for themselves that's happy where
they're reconciled to their families
even if their families are homophobic
now and will compensate for the pain
that they're in now and historically up
to this moment gay and lesbian adults
didn't feel comfortable talking to LGBT
teenagers about our realities because we
didn't want to be accused of being
pedophiles accused of recruiting and it
wasn't really until YouTube came along
in this kind of social media that we
could talk to them directly reach them
in their own homes without being accused
of recruiting really or trying to you
know touch them in inappropriate ways
we're just trying to touch their hearts
I've said in the past when I've talked
about coming-out I've talked about you
know in during high school and during
middle school homophobic families that
for gay men and lesbians and bi and
trans folks the coming-out process is
really our hero's journey and it often
is the only thing that is common across
all classes races sexual orientations
well in a sense it's the one unifying
experience in the LGBT life we're not
all from the same religious backgrounds
racial backgrounds economic backgrounds
but we all share this experience of
suffering really almost invariably and
coming out and healing and to see these
stories even as a gay to
is really touching and for gay kids to
see these stories when they're in the
midst of their hero's journey really
when they're being persecuted when
they're suffering to see people who've
emerged on the other side and are happy
and are healthy and are you know have
rewarding careers which does not mean
necessarily financially rewarding
careers for doing things they love the
people in their lives that they love is
wonderful and gay people really just
waiting for permission to share these
stories I felt forever that I'd hear
about a gay kid committing suicide and I
think I wish I could have talked to that
kid for five minutes
been able to tell him that gets better
but I couldn't talk to those kids I
couldn't talk to kids in Greensburg
Indiana or small towns in Texas and
small towns in California they have
permission their schools their parents
their churches are going to bring an
openly gay adults to talk to bully gay
kids about their lives and that it's
wonderful to be an openly gay adult and
what's happening as gay and lesbian and
bi and trans people all over the world
woke up and realized we didn't need
anyone's permission anymore
to talk to these kids that we can make
videos we could get on YouTube we can
use Twitter and Facebook and speak to
them directly and if need be really go
over the heads of their parents go over
the heads of their teachers and school
administrators and go over their heads
to their preachers and reach out to them
directly and save their lives
there are so many videos and I've
watched all of them that we've posted
that have touched me I've been sitting
in restaurants reviewing them with my
laptop and my headphones in and just
started to cry watching some of these
videos the the Texas Fort Worth Texas
City Councilmembers video that went
totally viral elements owned moved
people all over the country my friend
Jake shears made one that really touched
me
I think one of the things that yeah and
Tim Gunn's video where he talked about a
suicide attempt and no one knew about
that he'd never discussed publicly
before I think one of the things that
forget adults what we're getting out of
these videos watching these videos is
the is permission to really address this
pain you know we got out of high school
we got out of middle school we get away
from the bullies and we stuff all these
painful memories down down the whole
down inside and we don't think about
them anymore and you know I they're
friends of mine to put up videos where
they're talking about what they suffered
and they'd never told me I had no idea
what they'd survived